charlie charlie shell land é o que vocês
não têm tido ultimamente eu vou fazer
o lado diz só de quem fala é o dar que
seja muito bem vindo
jamais um vídeo e mostrados aqui um
vídeo que eu nunca pensei fazer porque
basicamente eu acho estúpido mas começou
o canal do terror e como vocês vão
perder muito eu vou fazer para comprovar
que isso não existe
ou então voltar logo e pra quem não anda
assim na internet não sabe o que é que
está a passar basicamente agora por aí a
viralizar o mundo é um xavante que o
charlie charlie xavante é invocar o
espírito mexicano supostamente este ano
ser provocar esse espírito que anda por
aí perdido mas não logo o jogo vai estar
na minha casa eu vou ter de usar dois
lápis uma folha nessa folha vou ter
respostas sim e não é basicamente eu vou
perguntar se eu tá ao pé de mim e eu vou
responder que sim então porque não
existe demônio nem espírito nem fantasma
nenhum do méxico vamos lá então o que
interessa é fazer o desafio eu vou
começar por é pagaram no já tenho aqui
duas câmaras não sei só sei que estava
aí a macumba que aponta pra minha cara o
caraças o chapéu já a banda ainda não
consultou a fio a vela java no youtube
usar duas câmeras mesmo pra vocês vêem
criou não vou superar eu não vou fazer
nada eu nem vou tocar nos lápis e tem
aqui as velas também para comprovar que
eu não vou esperar porque seus próprios
elas vão ganhar né
é lógico hora la roque eu vou fazer que
o diagrama do desafio quase que meteu
uma cruz e aqui temos que essa é que é
essa aqui não é assim
ok é é mais ou menos disto a piscina
está completamente apoiado no lápis
baixo e agora é só fazer algumas
perguntas em inglês é importante é que
nós charro inglês não sabe falar
português ganho se isso resultar em um
vôo ele é te afastar das velas para não
ter influência nenhuma do movimento
nenhum direito sobre natural locais
vamos lá então perguntei quem tem inglês
charlie charlie are you there
nada aconteça
só que algumas pessoas dizem que isto
tem que tentar algumas vezes porque o
espírito é preguiçoso e mexicana é
preguiçoso a gente tem que tentar
algumas vezes rock charlie charlie
arildo era é não me parece que eu esteja
me cheira a fazer alguma coisa do gênero
no méxico isso não mexe não está a
acontecer na vida charlie charlie está
aí em 2000 português maxicar no dml e
não sei porque eu tô primeiro eu tô
primeiro eu não sei por que esse desafio
é estúpido mas mete medo só para você né
das velas porque velas é uma sina de de
cemitério cemitério tem mortos microfone
aberto não pode haver nada
charlie charlie wilson ano pois vi times
eu acho que eu não entendo meu inglês
charlie charlie rio rio nada não mexe
não mexe na de charlie charlie está já
aí está outra vez charlie shannon e
posteriormente na índice é dúvida pensou
se não não parece à toa que há cinco
minutos e nada acontece
raul chaves está aí já o chao e sob a
data das velas também estão quietas nada
de anormal
também terá só não chove aí que o telão
nem a gritar lá vai não dá é impossível
afirmou
tudo mentira tudo mentira
como é que todos acredita um tudo
mentira tudo mentira não extingui lo nos
lobbies